self.com a new article from self.com
what the future of fitness really looks
like it's time to break free from
fitness's anti-fatness for many the
world of fitness can be far more
limiting than freeing in gyms on social
media and in other fitness dedicated
spaces the focus on what our bodies look
like can make it hard for those with
bodies that don't conform to narrowly
defined norms to feel like they belong
for far too long people with larger
bodies have been met with limitations
judgment and intimidation in space is
designed to help us all reach our
potentials over the last few years
thanks to the body positivity movement
as well as other thoughtful explorations
that have challenged complacent ideas
about weight and size we've seen an
important shift in how we discuss larger
bodies but fitness spaces can be a final
frontier in a particular strain of body
discrimination where anti-fat bias and
weight related stigma are all entrenched
in our collective understanding of what
it means to be
fit it's time to break free from this
limited view the future of fitness is
about making space for everyone to feel
welcome so in this package we're
celebrating the people who are helping
us to get there fitness is already a
practice of the privileged requires time
money and access that many people don't
have fat people have to jump those
hurdles
and more just to get to the gym
and when they do they're often met with
judgment discrimination and calorie
lectures they didn't ask for the problem
keeping fat people out of the gym is not
to their fatness the problem is fat
phobia we have a bunch of really helpful
service pieces if you're someone
wondering how to navigate fitness spaces
in a larger body they include how to
find a gym that's size friendly how to
respond to anti-fat encouragement when
you're working out how to feel confident
starting at the gym and mirna valerio's
useful gear roundup of 12 pieces of
running gear that can make running in a
larger body more comfortable
what do you think about that gentleman
the body positivity thing
works in one direction usually so
i think
both of you guys i've seen get
not body shamed because that's maybe a
bit strong but like made fun of for your
physiques in some way like something you
know chris that your forearms are
ridiculous or johnny that oh you can
stop sticking your chest out now mate
like i remember the bouncer saying or
people just
and these comments are all fine to throw
out someone for how they look if their
body
is muscular but it's not so much if if
it's fat
and so there is some
there are some kind of still underlying
unspoken
parts of what you can and can't say
equally
the
they're right that
this attitude does stop people from
wanting to get started with fitness
because they feel it's inaccessible and
they see the
um
the instagram ideal
bodies and and think oh well i'm so far
away from that i don't feel welcome in
that place and i think that's perfectly
valid um
but i would say there are many
things that you can train that don't
revolve around what your body fat is if
you join a power lifting gym you'll be
you'll be welcomed because among friends
among friends because the goal there is
how much weight can you lift and in many
cases
if you are fatter or if you're able to
get fat quickly
very helpful you can get strong yeah
well
i i fundamentally disagree that gyms are
a place that people who are of a larger
size aren't accepted into in gyms you
have a place how can you say that gyms
are unforgiving to fat people when it's
filled with former fat people like it is
it's select for people that used to be
fat i've never seen if you see a big guy
coming to our gym
you will see him get
far far more encouragement than a guy
which who is in shape or a girl
absolutely that's that's the reality of
it because people aren't dicks in gyms
they're you know they're there to
improve themselves and but i think it's
more the perception it's that oh look
everyone in there is in good shape and
i'll feel out of places but that's not
that's not what the article's saying
what the article is saying is that there
is discrimination anti-fat bias weight
related stigma entrenched in our
collective understanding and
judgment they met with judgment
discrimination and calorie lectures they
didn't ask for the problem keeping fat
people out of the gym is not their
fatness the problem is fat phobia that
immediately externalizes the locus of
control right this is just [ __ ] npc
thinking 101 it's not high agency
behavior it's a victim mentality
and
i was i thought god here we go more
virtue signaling from a company that is
basically giving people
chicken soup for this high calorie
chicken soup for the soul around fat
phobia but then i saw that they actually
provide what looks like pretty good
quality workout routines for people that
maybe don't understand how to use the
gym or are a little bit bigger so
there's a girl roxanne the diva or
something on youtube and she's you know
giving people very very basic bodyweight
movements that you can just follow along
with and that's for free so you go okay
so these people know what at least
movement looks like but the rhetoric and
the virtue signaling here is
i don't think that there is anybody that
i can think of that this would make feel
better that actually wants to feel that
way ethan supply my buddy 550 pounds
like 10 years ago when he filmed uh
remember the titans
now 220 pounds at no point does he want
to be told
yeah man the reason that you can't get
fit is because of everybody else it's
because of this discrimination which
i've never seen in 15 years of training
and i think if i did see in the gym i'd
go up to someone and say
excuse me mate what the [ __ ] do you
think you're doing this person has
obviously had to overcome
you know some concerns around getting
into a gym to get here why wouldn't you
support them and every single time
someone big does step into the gym we do
yeah there's a video going round of um
you know there's a
famous personal trainer who does sort of
sassy videos in durham or stockton um
are like team rp or team oh yeah yeah
you know what i mean and there's a video
of him going up to someone and
confronting them
because
previously the day before he was in that
guy's gym
with a mate who was overweight and he
was kind of um
berating him for for being overweight
and he was and he was like oh no just
banter you don't know what the
relationship's like between me and him
and and the and this guy was confronting
him saying well no it's still it's
unacceptable so and that's not out of
place you know that's that's accepted
that you shouldn't be addicted to people
i think that's totally that's totally
valid
did you see sorry johnny did you see
titania mcgrath andrew doyle tweeted
saying
this article proves that fat people are
just as fit as so-called athletes so why
is it that fat people are still so
underrepresented in competitive sports
like it it doesn't surprise me that it
wouldn't surprise me if the meritocracy
that sport is based around i like you
come first if you're the fastest
there will be a complaint down the line
of why are fat people underrepresented
in elite sport like that absolutely
could be something that i could see
happening a headline whereas the whole
definition of sport is that it's based
on performance and a bunch of other
factors not just fatness you know you're
how early you were in
brought into the sport and how much
money your your parents and your coach
and your team had to push push you
behind this thing and um all these other
kind of social factors that are beyond
your control
and so but but people like to pick
whatever their particular bug bear is to
say ah this is not
this doesn't fit my agenda in sport so
obviously trans athletes is the the big
one recently but not as big as obesity
in sport you suffer
about people
um yeah but the
so i actually took issue more with the
mechanics of the workout video
just
because as as you know when someone is
doing so you sometimes see people warm
up in the gym and they do rotate a cuff
warm up like that
it's not against gravity like what are
you doing or like twisting a dumbbell or
so so doing a wood chop without any kind
of cable resistance
is not a wood chop you're just moving
your arms in the air
it's a wood shop without the axe
or without the cable but the whole point
of the wood is it's through the
resistance resistance
[ __ ] man like
the definition of fitness trying to
re-jig the definition of fitness it's
time to uh look at our collective
understanding of what it means to be fit
so the crossfit definition of fitness
remaining that's the sport of fitness
and also has the title of the fittest on
earth athlete your work domain across
broad time and modal work capacity
across broad time and modal domains 10
components cardiovascular respiratory
endurance stamina strength flexibility
power speed coordination agility balance
and accuracy you are as fit as you are
competent in each of these 10 skills
i would be very very interested to hear
from someone that thinks that they can
give us a better definition of what
fitness is
than that and i definitely don't think
that it's going to come from
self.com i just don't see it i don't see
the things that this article is claiming
happen and i've been in a lot more gyms
than most of the people that write the
article like it's not about it not
happening to me it's about the way that
i feel when i'm in there and what i see
as well so here's an example because the
three of us have been to a yoga class
and the three of us are very out of
place we're not fit for yoga we're not
made for it it's all of yourself
and
[Laughter]
and so like i i certainly if i'm in a
yoga class and i'm like out the front i
feel a bit of like oh god people must
you know there's all the internal
narrative like people must think like
what what a willy like what's he doing
there or he's just here to creep on the
the yoga pants or or all these kind of
like things that you know
aren't true but they're just kind of
background thoughts because you're like
well i'm out of place here and i'm quite
i stick out like a sore thumb
so
it's just that but of course with you
know
when you come out of the thing and
you're like oh actually that's just
i have no proof of that that's just my
internal projections there yeah do you
know do you not credit like europe
because all three of us did it and we
didn't none of us talked about that at
the time like maybe afterwards when
you're sort of falling over or like
shaking and trying to hold the position
but
i credit my
like
comfort in that situation to just
i guess those feelings that existed the
first time you slept in the gym and they
they exist in my mind anyway no matter
what you look like
because you may look like you fit the
part but then
you get under a barbell and you don't
you still don't know what you're doing
well i don't feel like everyone's
looking at you one of the interesting
models that gets missed off when we're
talking about body positivity it's only
ever from fat to less fat it's never
from really skinny guy
to
growing and getting bigger you know the
only time you would ever see people that
are super leaner perhaps girls have had
eating disorders and anorexic but i've
never seen an article ever written about
that from a reputable source talking
about how you can gain muscle as
somebody that previously had an eating
disorder however lucy davies tons of
people that we know and we follow online
have previously had eating disorders and
now we're in the most ridiculous shape
because they've got all of the leanness
of when they were
with
great muscle added on top and that
that's a big pain point as well if
you've ever seen you know those old kind
of
cartoons like recess and all these
american like school bully type hey
the skinny kid every time yeah and so
that's skinny kid stepping into the gym
i don't
i don't know it it seems to me like
there is a a particular talking point
that people know and i mean [ __ ]
we're the ones giving it more airtime
right but i just think that if you're
the sort of person
that
anybody that's listening to this doesn't
have npc thinking so they're already not
taken in by that
high calorie chicken soup for the soul
but
if you are tempted to think about that
go okay like does this actually make my
situation any better at all or can i
find someone that i can go to the gym
with and once i step in there realize
that all of these concerns and all of
these rumors are only believed by people
who have never been to a gym in their
life
that's the key metric it's
does this improve accessibility for
people who are obese to get into the gym
and start exercising and if it doesn't
if it reinforces these structures and
makes you feel like
their fears like
yeah if it confirms your fears or kind
of
plays to them then
that's doing the opposite it's
discouraging people from going so we
need to find this balance of how do you
make it as accessible as possible and
friendly and inclusive
without
exploiting people's fears and
if you experience the the negativity
that you go to a gym and people are
nasty to you but you've decided you want
to lose weight or gain weight or
whatever
that i just don't think
stopping the pursuit entirely is a very
like sustainable strategy to approach
anything in life because no matter what
you do no matter what you pick even once
you're in shape you'll have people
telling you you're taking it too far
you'll have people telling you that
protein shakes are causing all sorts of
health concerns like it doesn't end
so
if you want to not embark on the journey
that's fine
but at all points along the journey the
same problem in various grades in and
out of the gym will just exist well this
is what i think the article is trying to
convince people of the fact that
actually maybe the gym is the scary
place that you always thought it was
you shouldn't be going you don't need to
go these are some of the problems this
is why your fears should be confirmed as
opposed to just stress testing it for
yourself heading into a gym and
realizing that almost everyone in there
has been fat you are in a place that
selects for people who are going out of
their way to try and change their bodies
but that's not that's not the group of
people that are going to say to you are
you going to the gym again are you what
are you going there for
like that's that's what it's like being
in being a young british guy who goes to
the gym instead of deciding to go on
another night out at uni yeah that's the
accusation or what you're doing that for
do you do you're not made to this
anymore you're not too good for us now
yo
no i really want to get my push workout
in in the morning because i'm on 531 and
it's peak week and next week i get to
deload and play like i listen to wisdom
and modern wisdom
bought bitcoin um but yeah i just think
this
it's npc thinking people shouldn't
listen to it
the
self.com can do better than this they
definitely can but in the meantime
i i don't think that a place which is
full of former fat people like the gym
is
it's going to be that unforgiving
just watch the jocko willing
good video and then just go anyway
if you enjoyed that then press here for
the best clips from the podcast over the
last few weeks and don't forget to
subscribe peace